queremos encontrar el siguiente límite
el límite de cuando x tiende a infinito
de la siguiente expresión va a ser una
función racional es 4x cuadrada menos 5x
y todo eso de ahí dividido entre 1 menos
3 x cuadrada ahora infinito es un número
extraño entonces no podemos simplemente
poner x igual infinito en la expresión y
ver qué sucede pero si quisiéramos
entender qué le pasa a este límite
podemos preguntarnos qué le pasa a la
expresión conforme aquí se hace muy muy
muy grande entonces podemos ver que
conforme x se hace muy muy grande el
numerador también el numerador tiende a
infinito y en el denominador si ponemos
una equis muy muy grande eso también
bueno no se va precisamente a infinito
3x cuadradas y se va a infinito pero le
estamos restando entonces si restamos
algo que se va a infinito algo que no es
infinito eso se va a menos infinito
entonces bueno vamos a poner aquí a la
derecha eso que acabamos de decir así si
digamos que evaluamos el infinito
entonces en el numerador nos queda
infinito y en el denominador obtenemos
menos infinito lo voy a poner por aquí
menos infinito y esto que queda es una
de las formas indeterminadas a las que
se les puede aplicar lo hospital a lo
mejor te preguntes para qué estamos
haciendo esto si yo ya sé hacer este
límite sin usar el hospital tiene razón
probablemente se pasó más bien debería
saber hacerlo de otra forma pero lo que
quiero enseñarte es que la regla del
hospital funciona para este tipo de
problemas para los problemas que tengan
una forma del estilo infinito entre más
menos infinito entonces vamos a aplicar
la regla del hopital entonces para
aplicar la regla del hopital hay que
pensar que si este límite existiera debe
existir el límite del cociente de las
derivadas entonces este límite debería
ser igual al límite de cuando x tiene
infinito y vamos a derivar a ver qué
pasa la derivada del numerador la
derivada numeral de 4x cuadrada es 8x lo
voy a poner aquí 8 x hay que restarle 5
y eso hay que dividirlo entre la
derivada del denominador la derivada de
uno es cero la derivada de menos 3x
cuadrada es menos 6x
entonces una vez más si intentamos
evaluar en infinito el numerador se va a
infinito y en el denominador tenemos
menos 6 por algo muy muy grande tres
menos seis por infinito quedan menos
infinito lo pongo por aquí menos
infinito entonces hay que aplicar la
regla del hopital una vez más si el
límite de este cociente existiera debe
existir el límite del cociente de las
derivadas del numerador y del
denominador y hasta país de trabalenguas
pero sigamos entonces a ver este límite
debe ser igual al límite de cuando x
tiende a infinito de d vamos a cambiar
el color de la nada pues vamos a poner
la derivada de 8x menos 5 s es 8 y luego
la derivada menos 6x esa es menos 6 y
eso de aquí ya nos queda una constante
pero sabemos que el límite de una
constante sin importar a dónde tienda la
variable es la constante entonces
simplemente podemos poner esta cosa
simplificada nos queda 4 entre menos 3
entonces nos queda menos 4 entre 3 menos
cuatro tercios entonces este límite
existe en medio habiten hemos una forma
indeterminada aplicando la regla del
hopital concluimos
el límite de enmedio también existe y es
igual al de abajo que es menos cuatro
tercios aplicando el argumento una vez
más para el límite original obtenemos
que también vale menos cuatro tercios y
para todos aquellos que les quedaba la
duda si también se podía hacer factor
izando una equis cuadrada están
totalmente en lo correcto y lo voy a
resolver así aquí al lado para que
veamos que un problema puede tener
muchas soluciones entonces bueno para
este tipo de problema en realidad yo
hubiera hecho eso que ustedes dicen yo
hubiera factor izado una equis cuadrada
entonces vamos a poner problema aquí el
límite de cuando x tiende a infinito de
4x cuadrada menos 5 x dividido entre 1
menos 3 x cuadrada entonces esta
expresión la vamos a poner igual al
límite de cuando x tiene infinito
déjenme poner una separación por aquí
para indicar que esta igualdad viene de
arriba y no de la izquierda entonces
este límite es igual al límite cuando x
tiene infinito de vamos a factorizar una
x cuadrada una x cuadrada multiplicada
por 4
por 45 entre x
verdad x cuadrada x menos 5 / x es menos
5 x eso de ahí dividido vamos a
factorizar una x cuadrada en el
denominador x cuadrada x 1 / x cuadrada
menos 3 ahí está entonces estas dos x
cuadradas de aquí se van a cancelar las
tachamos y entonces eso va a ser igual
al límite de cuando x tiende a infinito
de cuatro menos 5 / x eso de ahí
dividido entre 1 entre x cuadrada menos
3 y ahora qué pasa cuando aquí se hace
muy muy grande conforme x se hace súper
super duper mega grande el denominador
se hace muy muy grande y esto tiende a
cero entonces lo ponemos así le ponemos
cero y aquí abajo esta fracción también
se hace cero entonces lo único que nos
queda es un 4 entre menos 3 y esto es
igual a menos cuatro tercios y en efecto
no teníamos que estar a fuerza al
hopital y existía esta otra solución de
alternativa